I have a dream  you see I'm so glad you're here  I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do  this by myself  your mother is the greatest person ever  made baby  let me tell you how she did it all on  her own  [Music]  right short the world is wide  I want to make some memories  this dress might look very pretty on you  you don't know me at all do you  [Music]  I think we should stay here together I  wish I could stay here too  turns out he's engaged I hate it when  they do that I was cheated by you you  know look at me now will I ever learn I  don't know how but I suddenly lose  control there's a fire within my never  felt closer to my mama she wasn't scared  because she had me  here I go  we can't tell anybody else about the  baby okay  I just told bill and I told Harry I told  many many people let's get the party  started  grandma you weren't invited that's the  best kind of party little girl